hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey
I'm Jason Dolan Jason Dolan is joining
us today he is a really close friend of
ours is actually our patron - who bought
us this camera right here little bit off
of that's how easy it is to get on this
channel just by us cameras recording
equipment film equipment
it's a quickest way to get to Greg's
heart just buy him stuff thanks Jason
you know me well I have credit cards so
a still paid for the active a working
screenwriter he saw bright burn last
night we saw it a couple nights ago
it's the biggest movie in America right
now believe it's open up to like 100
million dollar reason no one really is
our little Smith yeah we'll give some
quick thoughts on it in case you haven't
seen it to give you enough time for like
the quick non-spoiler review and then
we'll just hop right into everything Jon
once you kick us off what are your
thoughts I enjoyed this movie quite a
bit I mean I do agree with some of the
gripes that it could be a better
deconstruction of superhero movies it
could be a more dramatic family story of
some kind but for what I wanted and for
kind of the mood I had going in I
thought it was really tight really
straightforward really effective and the
concept is enough to take it pretty far
so yeah I had a great time for myself I
really enjoyed the how the film was kind
of a metaphor for like what happens when
your two parents and you have this kid
doing all of these atrocities maybe a
disturbed child it was really great how
they put it in in the world of Superman
of like these parents like specifically
the mother Elizabeth Banks always in
denial about how awful her kid is and
all of these things that he's doing and
defending him even against the husband
you know who's trying to be practical
about it and and to me that's what what
I really loved about bright burn that it
was more than a superhero horror film
but it actually I think dealt with some
very real issues under the guise of
superhero horror film I don't know what
this whole superhero horror thing is
it's going around because I never
expected superhero element infused and
this is at all I thought the movie was
just fine honestly before we talked
about this you told me kind of what you
were
affecting you told me kind of what your
expectations were at and I feel like my
expectations were a little bit higher
than both of yours I thought the first
trailer for this movie was more
effective than the entirety of this film
if you know it's a low-budget film
before than some big Sony Pictures
advertised the production and you know
didn't have all this like crazy
marketing to go behind it I probably
wouldn't have expected as much I
probably wouldn't be able to just accept
this as it's a really good like b-movie
horror slasher flick with a superhero
twist to it of possessed child might
just stumble on it yeah because I
couldn't help but watch this movie and
think of how this could have been not
just fine or you know passable horror
film to something that's actually great
I felt like this could have been a great
very emotionally effective film if they
had done a little bit more with it
that's into the non-spoiler taught to do
is now hop into the rest of the
airplanes cuz you know how in the first
trailer they did a really good job at
making you go it's look like a Man of
Steel ripoff and then as it progressed
you're like oh wait a minute this is
looking a little bit twisted this is
look oh they're perverting mrs. steel
this is what a Superman went crazy you
know I thought this movie could have
actually benefited a lot from having
more of that approach I think all the
concepts are there the premise is there
but I felt that this was a very rushed
movie it seemed like it was in a rush to
get to like let just make him evil right
away instead of having like a natural
build-up to it I've heard quite a few
reviews on this and it seems like
everyone's kind of giving their own
pitch on what would have made this
better for me when I was watching this I
kept thinking you know if they just
spent act 1 building a sense of wonder
to the powers you know just like kind of
committing to a Man of Steel ripoff yeah
a Superman story ripoff you slowly start
to let like oh it's going from Wonder
and slowly descending really spend time
to feel the town of bright burn really
spend time to feel the characters other
than Elizabeth Banks and who know who
plays the dad again at David Denman he's
ground in the office both of ya Roy from
the office I think they're both great in
this movie I think the performers are
better than the writing in this movie I
do think this film is shot really well
there's some really cool visuals some of
my favorite shots are actually just when
they're driving down the dark road and
the way you're feeling the environment
at the woods like there's some beautiful
imagery in here
gets cut in the eye and how half the
screen is red you know there was a lot
of really fun little ideas that were
injected in this film see I feel like
that's pretty much how I feel about the
movie yet it's fun it's entertaining but
for just a straightforward home movie I
didn't find it necessarily scary I just
feel like it could have kept diving
deeper and deeper well I'll just say for
myself I kind of equated to this a
little bit too like the first Mad Max a
very low-budget Australian police cop
you know whose wife is killed and just
kind of goes after these guys it created
this world that we were able to build on
with the road wire and Beyond
Thunderdome and eventually a fury road I
look at bright bird as having the
potential to spawn you know a much
bigger world and that's what I really
really loved especially with the Michael
Rooker character at the very end which
was the the better version of what Zack
Snyder tried to do in Batman vs Superman
it's just saying that there were more
people like this possibly out there
being like a you know a low-budget film
my expectations always going in are a
little lower and so I was really
impressed with what they were able to
accomplish I mean the way that Brandon
takes out David Denman I wanted to see
that my whole life and I thought it was
incredibly well shot and Matt Jones from
Breaking Bad bad I was just blown away
by the makeup effects and the reality of
that situation and I do know that they
cut some scenes as often happens that
would have been those relationships and
characters a little bit more and I'm
actually really would be interested in
seeing that on the DVD or the digital
download overall I thought that
Elizabeth Banks you know really did an
incredible job as the mother the kid I
forget his name who was ant-man an end
game right Jackson ain't done the actor
and he was really good like I really
liked that guy a lot I was pleasantly
for possessed child actor that kind of
performances kind of annoys me I was
actually not annoyed by him there was
writing issues I had with it yeah you
know he has that scene where he says I
want to do good where's that coming from
exactly like he was mocking her by
saying that like that's the only way it
made any sense to me a child's idea of
what's good also you're talking about
I'm just gonna call Roy Roy's death it
was about
halfway through this movie when I
actually started give a [ __ ] about
character after the boy comes home and
he makes up this whole lie about being
bullied at soccer that's when I started
the movie was like oh I'm starting to
feel something finally for this movie
because it seems like it was in a rush
to become the slasher flick when I felt
like it could have been a good character
piece and really getting to know the
characters as opposed to just setting up
people with a few notes to meet so we
can kill them off in some cool ways and
some gory ways which are all fun in the
moment but in that moment right I had a
hard time getting on board with when he
shot his kid as cool as the death was as
cool as it was to be like oh we finally
got to see that Superman power really
come full using how deadly it can be
first off he kind of just seemed like he
made a big leap into I gotta kill this
kid there's a lack of inner conflict for
me of he's raised this kid as his own
son for 10 years it's only very recently
when he started to show signs
I felt like there should have been more
complexity to okay he's an alien he's
got these powers clearly but he's also
my son and I felt like that the whole
thing about he's also my son just
started getting really pushed down way
too fast I felt like when he shoots the
kid his kid he probably should have
gotten a little bit more evidence before
you're gonna finally conclude I'm gonna
try to shoot this kid in the head who he
also believes has never bled once in his
life you know wait a minute there's so
much lack of logic here is not enough
motional death this guy was not planning
it out to it you know when you get to
the moment with Elizabeth Banks death in
this movie when that happened I went Oh
neat she's dead I'm actually really cool
the movie went that way I loved that I
loved in concept I really liked it at
the same time I couldn't help but feel
that if the movie had done a better job
with really making you emotionally
invested in characters as opposed to
just being a fun entertaining film I
would have been heartbroken as opposed
to just going neat choice right like you
were talking about how this movie you
really impressed you with the potential
it has to go on as a franchise and
that's sort of my take away with this is
I felt so much potential but it never
quite met if there if I felt like they
actually played it rather safe they
could have gone a lot deeper I think an
extra 30 minutes could have really
helped this feel better where they I
kept thinking of the movie disturbia
when I was watching this cuz you know
how does the trail the first two
trailers for bright berm pretty much
ruin the whole movie for you except for
Elizabeth Banks dying and
the detail it was a couple of I actually
felt like there was maybe I start
stopped a void I started a bleeding the
trailers by the time I saw the movie I
felt there was a lot of stuff that I
didn't know was gonna happen it's funny
that you say that there are a lot of
them there are a lot of tonal layers you
don't expect from the trailer like there
are a lot of things that are unsettling
about it especially like when he's
trying to talk to the little girl in her
room like things like that I was like
this is a whole flavor I did not expect
to have to grapple with in this movie
see that element right there in terms of
writing honestly that whole thing made
me so uncomfortable in the right ways it
started making me think all these things
of like oh my god is that so many
pictures like I think you're not allowed
this kid to just flat out sexually
assault this like right role in this in
this movie like what they allow that
with the parents of these actors a lot I
was just going there he says like okay
I'll get rid of your mom because she
seems to be the obstacle but then never
comes back in the movie there's no
payoff to it it just sort of gets to
rock and there was so much setup and
investment for that to be something in
the film but it just gets canned for a
horror movie where there's a lot of jump
scares lots of cool like visual like
tricks with hey the kids their two kids
nothing it's not there I was never
really scared and the part that I was
most unsettled by was the possibility of
what could happen with these two kids
yet nothing ever became of it again I
think there was six some scenes that did
get cut from the film but for me I was
scared while I was watching this film
because I didn't know what was gonna
happen next and what this kid was gonna
do like I knew what was gonna happen in
the diner cuz that had been shown to us
in the trailer I knew that something was
gonna happen with badger and that was it
though I didn't really know like if he
was gonna kill this girl or not like I
didn't know if he was gonna I didn't
know he was gonna kill his mom I didn't
know if he was gonna kill his dad even
the aunt that was one where I was like
oh not really quite sure what happened
at the end of that but overall it still
worked for me in concept and a lot of
these films which again are low-budget
knowing how a lot of movies get made
also having seen a lot of terrible
horror films I thought this movie did
have a lot of heart behind it and what
it was trying to convey as this metaphor
for two parents with a child that they
don't know what to do is like you know
we can we can talk about Kevin
elephant a lot of these films like it
really was making my imagination go in a
direction that I wasn't expecting it to
go I was getting more out of this film
then superhero horror film like I was
getting parents not knowing how to deal
with their kids and hiding their child
like you think about Kevin Costner in
Man of Steel they're hiding it you know
but for the right reasons you know and
these parents are hiding it for the
wrong reasons that's just something that
connected with me that I did not expect
going into this film so I loved you know
I I really did I loved this movie coming
out of it but I think a lot of it does
come down to expectations I always
performs like this I have low
expectations I feel like you have low
expectations and it was better than what
you thought it was actly and you had
high expectations and it didn't meet
live up to the way that you wanted that
you would have written the movie or what
I've wanted to do yeah and I think
happens a lot in popular right I feel
like that can be unfair sometimes to
apply to a movie I did have a hard time
letting go of how I loved how the
trailer sold me on this sense of wonder
and a family vibe that I thought would
slowly start to go wrong the reason I
compared disturbia earlier disturbia
trailer show you the whole movie they
they show you he goes under house arrest
there's gonna be serial killer it was
across the street we're when they show
you all ya they show you all the thrills
but when you watch the actual movie of
disturbia there's none of that for like
a whole hour you know it's just like
you're hanging out above you're hanging
out with these kids you're really
invested so when when all this stuff
that that that's in the trailer already
starts happening it's still very intense
yeah and for me this was the opposite
because it kind of just seemed to have
this one note and the very early on like
this is a horror movie kid's gonna go
evil very early on there's really not
gonna be much of a build-up to it it was
just gonna switch one day and I even
thought the switch was a little cheesy
when he starts reading the notes take I
was expecting something that was a
little bit higher than b-movie horror
slasher film that's because to me I'm
like other than the fact that he has
superhero like Superman powers it's
pretty much a generic you know possessed
child me oh yeah I'd like the oh man yes
like that I mean one what place I'll
agree with you it's like I would have
loved another 20 minutes in this movie
first act I think it's really about 80
minutes long it's a short film you know
90 minutes with credits once we got past
the first clunky 10 to 15 minutes of the
film I did
get on board for the ride like I was
ultimately like I was almost able to
fill in the blanks in my own imagination
the visual effects for this movie for
only six million dollars I thought were
very impressed yes it's made for cheap
but doesn't look cheap yeah it does not
look they really smartly shot their
effects because I noticed in a lot of
scenes they would have the the CG stuff
be either out of focus or in motion blur
and then it would lead into a practical
gag and for a low-budget like you see a
lot of low-budget movies with a lot of
effects yeah
don't live up to it yeah and this movie
arguably really needs them too and I
thought they very cleverly handled yeah
that aspect is Mike Mike doubt or the DP
he did a fantastic job I think of the
way that he shot this film well the way
it shot it was likely the best things
about yeah that's what yes visually the
way it's shot and the parents
performances are like the saving grace
absolutely and I will say in terms of
writing usually in these movies I feel
like the parents are really stupid and I
just can't get on board with the parents
in this movie I liked how early on
Elizabeth Banks was very suspicious and
she was going do I need to take him to
see a specialist I thought there were
some well justified things about why
they don't think he needs to go see a
specialist and and some of the debates I
was really buying into their saving
graces in this movie that allow me to
just to never be bored I just couldn't
help but feel that there was so much
more they could have gone with it yeah I
mean I went into this movie basically
expecting a pretty straightforward
exploitation high-concept horror movie
the overall impression it left on me is
yeah they like based on that and knowing
it was gonna be kind of an quick movie
or at least a tightly paced movie I
found myself yeah pretty much enjoying
the whole thing for how you know compact
some of the elements are I understand
the criticisms but I thought I got at
least shades of all the criticisms it's
like the beginning of the movie we spend
a little time getting to know the kid
and I never expect the thing is this
movie gave me more than I expected in
terms of what it wanted to think about
not that it got super deep but yeah the
performances the parents and the
relationship dynamic feels lived-in
enough that yeah you're like okay this
is kind of like a troubled child
situation and it was enough for again my
expectation that it did endear me to the
movie and it got under my skin more than
I thought to the point that this is a
concept that for me I feel like
everybody has a concept of or two
that naturally scares them and so like
evil child is just a generally jarring
thing to me most of what freaks me out
in horror is like human grounded stuff
not usually the fantasy so this is a
fantasy that does freak me out because
not only is there a communication gap
between an adult and a child but there's
also yeah this accelerated aggression
angle that yeah you can't reason with
and there's nothing you can do about and
so yeah I thought it was nifty and tight
and effective I agree with a lot of the
criticisms but for my own personal
enjoyment I thought it was conscientious
for how straightforward it was in a
pretty effective be exploitation movie
with a little more to it than I would
have expected basically great
counter-programming for Aladdin I guess
I just have a hard time feeling like
this it's tight when when it felt very
rushed you know what I mean it seems
like you love it
Jon liked it more than you thought and I
was like I'm pretty low we have like
three very varieties of opinions here I
just felt like it could have used some
better character development especially
and I feel like what the kid they could
have done something like that too
because that was one of the appealing
parts of it you know there's Elseworlds
stories of Superman going to the dark
zone mm-hmm those are very fascinating
part of the fascination comes with that
is because he can do good but he decides
to do evil and in here I'm similar to
Chronicle you know Chronicle was really
real there's a great bound but you'll be
looking forward to a sequel to Piper and
I've seen more in this universe of maybe
you know the studio giving them a little
bit more money 15 million to really try
and take this character and and explore
it or another character I want to see
more of that Michael Rooker Alex Jones
I'm not sure it's made its money back
properly oh yeah if there was I'd go see
it anyway guys did you see bright burn
what do you think of it comment below
let us know what you think if you liked
this video please hit that like button
and before I wrap this up I would like
to give a patient the day shot to a man
named Scuba Steve huge horror enthusiast
he's also a guy who graffitis a lot very
legal stuff in a lot of ways he is like
the kid in bright burn for a man who
could do a lot of good with his art but
instead does a lot of crime
and you know what man we got to find
this guy and get him arrested as soon as
possible
APB what is what is this a movement
all-points bulletin so the police put
out review that handbook before you join
the force
scuba thanks for being in for so long
dude we haven't talked in a while but
you've kept your credit card on file and
that's all that counts
like I said full circle this review
that's right money makes Gregg happy